today we're going to talk about the
brothers karamazov and specifically one
section of that one chapter called the
grand inquisitor it's probably one of
the most often exerted portion of the
text and this is because there's there's
a classic confrontation that takes place
there and you can think of this chapter
as being something that's very easily
read and on a certain level very easily
understood once you know some of the
cultural reference and there there's not
too many difficult ones but one that
remains a mystery it still holds some
open questions for us that all point
towards more toward begun to this this
lecture so what's going on in this this
passage I actually am going to talk
about a little bit more than just this
particular chapter I'd like to look at
some of the other chapters that take
part in that this portion where Alyosha
and I are interacting with each other
there's Pro and contract
but first I want to say what's what's
going on and fundamentally yeah this
champion itself let's think about
narrative and also think about character
it's pretty simple when it comes to
character so we'll come back to that in
a moment and that'll make more sense
when we talk about narrative
what's going on we have several people
talking and then one of them tells a
story which actually becomes hold what
it means pull them in a somewhat
different sense then then we're used to
thinking and then we'll talk about that
in just a moment so there's a story and
within this story there is a
confrontation that takes place between
the giro Grand Inquisitor
and Jesus Christ come back to earth as
promised with what happens sometimes and
this is taking place some time during
the time of the Inquisition so who's
telling this story well this story about
these guys is being told why I haven't I
haven't affairs Makar massa
one of the brothers and Ivan himself is
speaking with his brother the ocean so
there is at the same time a larger love
story
here we can't - and who would be at the
very top of this would be Fyodor
Dostoevsky's telling us the story a
story larger story within which these
two brothers down the conversation
within the course at which one of the
brothers tells the story and it gets
even more convoluted yet because the
Grand Inquisitor himself is going to
tell the story as well he's going to try
it out at end of histories of human
beings and God and interactions
suffering happiness freedom all these
rows of X so you can think of what's
going on here is a process of
condensation or they think of it like
telescoping yet you've got this larger
project going on and then it gets much
more much more condensed until we
finally get to a very coherent
point of view being pulled by the Grand
Inquisitor it was really the central
character of this chapter although when
you notice that and then the janitor
itself now the ocean and I haven't
talked back and forth and they even make
some remarks about what's going on in
the story itself so that gives you a
little bit of the structure the
narrative also tells you a little bit
about characters but we should have just
spelled those out a little bit you know
depict them Jesus Christ is showing up
and he doesn't say a thing except at one
point where he actually does say the
famous words from the gospel that
come from aramaic tele the Kumi arrives
made other than that she doesn't say
anything throughout the entire piece he
does have a few very important gestures
but like gestures typically do there's
some ambiguity involved in the gesture
itself what is the meaning of what's
taking place what is the significance of
it it's not exactly easy to tell
interpretation on the other hand
somebody talked about a lot is the Grand
Inquisitor the Grand Inquisitor is a 90
year old man we know that he's a
cardinal we know that he's an Inquisitor
meaning that he was actually one of the
people who was charged with the task of
protecting the faith inquiring into the
condition of heretics there that as
people who had in one way or another set
themselves at odds with the Christian
faith by taking part of the Christian
faith and turning it against
understanding heresy now if you know
anything about the historical
inquisitions there were more than one
Inquisition
you know that a lot of abuses took place
during that time many people used it as
a cover for power or for greed or
sometimes even for self-protection
oftentimes religion and politics became
intimately intertwined with in this
interest interesting they had done when
it came to the Spanish Inquisition
before the whole ball got rolling the
religious leaders were involved with
that didn't want to be charged they
thought it was a bad idea who actually
was the driving impetus behind it it
wasn't they actually hope it wasn't
actually the Spanish Church it was
actually the king who was using the
Inquisition for his own political homes
but once it got going like a lot of
these things and then once they develop
the sort of momentum they allow all
these sort of ways in which people who
are less Heinlein didn't even those who
are fairly high minded but I was from
ideologically blind to insert' their
agendas into the mechanism and that's
sort of what's going on except that the
way that Ivan is depicting a Grand
Inquisitor he's not doing it for greed
he's not doing it solely for power he's
not doing it for all the you know perks
or pleasures where things like that
a job as a matter of fact it's
interesting you notice that the day
before when they were burning all the
heretics he's wearing this full
Cardinals garb so you could say very
dense clothes the next day people
earning a monk's out whether the action
actually takes place so what does he
motivated by that's part of the stories
of the best part what's going on here
he's going to tell you about his
motivation and in certain ways you can
understand what he's driving that
because he's a person who's genuinely
concerned for Humanity he wants to make
people happy and not just happy in the
sense of you know tell him to jokes or
you know buy them something some nice
things he wants to figure out what makes
human beings tick what would satisfy
their deepest desires and then go about
actually trying to satisfy them so in a
certain way you can think of him as a
philanthropist as a humanist as a
reformer that's the Grand Inquisitor
he's also blind to certain ways there's
also something more going on so that's
at this level what about these guys
well the book is The Brothers Karamazov
and it's about these brothers and all
the other characters who are excited
with their world and the father they
don't all get along I'm not going to try
to go into the you know very
labyrinthian complex storylines here
that those JSP lays out just a part of
it is you know there's no way we could
possibly do justice to it suffice it to
say at this point
story Alyosha is in fact a postulate he
wants to become a monk he is about to
leave the monastery he is looking at
getting married since he is leaving the
monastery he had he's not named he is a
very loving in certain ways even timid
soul but we often have this this picture
of religious people as if they were
destroyed withdrawing themselves from
world entirely and very to be how do you
saying they're not streetwise they have
no sense about you know what makes human
beings tick they make stupid mistakes
now the Osho he makes some mistakes and
do all those to his characters but he
actually has some pretty keen insights
into human nature and you know you can't
actually go into religious life without
learning about the aspects of yourself
that you might have actually concealed
up until that point dig into yourself
this goes whether you're whether you're
talking about say Christian monasticism
or Buddhist monasticism and you
monasticism Islamic Sufism all of these
promote assert ourself scrutiny sort of
exploration of who one has
tick and as well as what makes other
people take in how you relate to them
and you can see that in LA I only is a
religious believer although not too far
from this this section he actually asks
his fiancee we know something what would
it surprise you to learn that I don't
believe in God he doesn't actually say
this but he's testing waters I have
another hand is this very dynamic
somewhat tortured soul he's the older
brother to do nelio show and he has
traveled abroad he is fairly worldly he
lives a secular kind of life he he
claims that that he doesn't buy into all
of his religious stuff as a matter of
fact you could interpret the whole story
that you tell us it's sort of like one
big you know knockout blow against
religion that's a surface level reading
of it but actually the story's a bit
more complicated and so maybe it's
better mine doesn't even so that's her
narrative that's our characters let's
now look at two of those what is I can
call this at home this whole chapter he
and Alyosha are having an argument about
God whether he had exist about what that
would mean and he says well they get to
the point where Alyosha makes reference
to Christ in order
trying to talk about the meaning of
sucker they just get this blonde
involved conversation which is worth
reading for its own sake in which I have
to leave out some of the terrible things
that happen all sufferings that children
undergo that adults actually take
pleasure in inflicting on them and he
says look this does not make sense to me
I'm not saying that I'm absolutely good
God couldn't countenance this but the
way that religious people are talking
about this that somehow it all balances
out in some sort of general
harmonization or forgiveness that
doesn't jive with you know there's
something also about my desire to see
that the guilty punishment that doesn't
sit right either so Elio sure brings in
Christ and at that point five it says
you mean the one that's in and just what
no I haven't forgotten about it indeed I
was wondering how long it would take you
to bring it into our discussion because
the people on your side usually make use
of him above all of their arguments you
know well don't laugh now about a year
or so ago I compose a sort of poem and
if you're willing to waste say another
ten minutes with me I could recite it to
you OSHA says you wrote a poem and it
says I don't know I didn't write a whole
per se I've never written the two verses
of my whole life but I didn't think it
up and then memorized I composed it in a
moment of real inspiration when you'll
be my first reader I mean audience so he
says the poem is called the Grand
Inquisitor and that's that's the chapter
why does he call it a poem well you know
we have been differently
country nowadays then people did
throughout most of the history and at
the time one does we have seen a few of
us may have memorized poems in school
and if you did that can be quite good it
gives you an object that you can wrap
your head around any poem that's
actually worth being called home
articulates a view of reality it may be
as small as just you know this bottle
cap but it tells you about that that
bottle cap it reveals to you sides of it
that you can't see before they may not
even be beautiful sighs you know
Baudelaire a great French poet one of my
favorites made a career out of writing
about ugliness many people's poetry in
the 20th century in the 21st century it
seems to well what determines whether
it's really a worthwhile poem is whether
it sticks with you whether it's
something that you once you've seen you
have to be coming back to that's what
this is for
and I think in a certain way it is for
emotion and if Dostoevsky
magic works on us his skill as craft as
a narrator this becomes something that
we end up having stuck in our heads as
well just like we would a song that
really captivates
we keep thinking about it not just
singing but thinking about you know
think about for example cat's in the
cradle but I retained them now that I've
said it as promised I'm in your head
it's all of it
yeah it doesn't articulate it doesn't
matter tick you late a clear message
well you should live your life this way
this way this way
it does tell you you probably should
spend time with your family like camp
but it does so in the wedding way and
that's why it has its power that's why
it stays with you there's a certain
sense of mystery in every poem and
that's there in the story of the Grand
Inquisitor so I just wanted to say a few
words about what it means for us to be
at home the other thing I'm going to do
before we actually start the analyzing
this this very interesting chapter is
mention a few important remarks and
passages in the chapters just before
this remarks that are made either by
Alyosha we're by item that I think lend
a certain context and color and
character to the granite visitor passage
so one of these is Alyosha and he is
saying striking about the law and he
says well Ivan it's just he's talking
about love it I love those sticky little
leaves in the spring of the blue sky
that's what you don't love those things
with reason with logic you love it with
your innards with your belly and that's
how you love your own first youthful
strength sort of romantic or appreciate
however we want to call it now it's not
connected with reason it's not connected
with logic it's something you feel not
something you think about
Alyosha says I understand it only too
well it's the innards and the belly that
long to love you put it wonderfully and
I'm terribly glad that you have such an
appetite for life your pride
I always thought that before anything
else people she should learn to love
life in this world and that his brother
says to love life more than the meaning
of life now that's two very different
things about that there is life in the
sense of what one experiences what what
is going on and then there's the meaning
of life there's the significance of
things being put together and these are
clearly not the same thing it's kind of
interesting to the Alyosha says learn to
love learning learning is very lot of
intellectual practice rote and manners
so learning to love one has to wonder
about that so that Alyosha says yes
that's right that's that's the way it
should be
love should come before logic just as
you said only then will man be able to
understand the meaning of life and this
is very profound this is something that
you see in a lot of different religious
leaders
also within some of the other group of
the distributions the notion that
knowledge is in some way dependent on
that knowledge in the full sense
requires loving the object and not just
loving the self not just loving what you
get from the object but loving that
thing to really know a person even to
fully desire to go in person you have to
at least in some sense love them you
have to love something about them so how
that was really hitting in something key
here only after one love will want to be
able to understand the meaning of life
that's a the important prefiguring of
this chapter you'll see why so that's
one passage another passage is where
this is a very comic passage I think
actually especially the philosopher
myself it's where I have been just
talking about what are we up to here
what are we gonna do and he says you
know I'm gonna be leaving pretty soon it
may not be you know morning maybe later
on we're going to lunch together here
you and I still have plenty of time to
spend together before I leave a Holy
Trinity and then his brothers knows what
kind of eternity is it if you're leaving
tomorrow axis why should that concern us
as long as we have time to settle all
the manners we've met to discuss well
why do you look so surprised
tell me yourself that why we met was it
to talk about the many mansions a bunch
of sweet news of the day did we meet for
the ass at the purpose of our meeting
and then the Alyosha says no I don't
think so
so you know yourself what the purpose
was
it's different with other people we can
use we have first of all the settlement
verities that worried us these are
enough men and they are concerned with
the question the point of things the big
issue what is the meaning of life and
you know this question of what is the
meaning of life if you want to truly get
to know somebody you have to ask that
question not just in general but workers
back to that person so I had been hurt
with his relationship with his brother
is to get to know what makes his brother
tick what is the meaning of life for his
brother yeah I'll show you in return in
order to know whether the end to love is
a brother has to try to wrap its head
around
means firstly he has to find out what
makes him tick
what does he think about things and you
know it's not just about trivial things
do you like mayonnaise or mustard things
like that what kind of music do you
enjoy all that could be that could have
significance you were a red tie or a
blue tie it's about the big things what
do you think is the greatest good are we
capable of that are we bound to be
locked in conflict with each other or is
it possible for there to be harmony is
there a cop just got care about us I
mean he's fated to do what we do or do
we have something like free will how far
does free will go these are the sorts of
things that really determine how you do
like these are many calls need eternal
verities it says all the young Russia is
talking about nothing but those eternal
questions just at the moment with the
old generation has suddenly turned its
attention to practical problems so this
grand inquisitor passage this is part of
two brothers trying to argue with each
other
about what the point that the world is
at the point of itself is points of
other people and relations that all
these other sorts of big issue things
that are all bound up together what
those that's just going together so
that's important passage as well
another important passage that we're
kind of jumping a little bit here is
where they're going to talk about God
and Ivan says something really
interesting and he's admitting his own
limits here he says from what I've heard
it once it's not great but when Mendte
to God the enemy I won't bother to
repeat to you almost fashion axioms
accepted by our Russian boys blog and
he's sort of you know spinning his
wheels a little bit and then it suddenly
says for what is the purpose of this
conversation between us this purpose as
I understand it is for me to explaining
as briefly as possible what I am
that is what sort of man idea what I
believe in what I hope so I just need
here play and briefly that I accept God
but I must point out one thing that God
does exist and if they really created
the world then as we well know he
created it according to the principles
of Euclidean geometry and man the human
brain capable of grasping only three
dimensions of space so what are you
saying there I just want to stop for a
moment he's saying if there's a god he
created its world he created an
according to certain structures
rules and he created the human brain
able to interpret and fully understand
those those structures yet there he have
been and still are mathematicians and
philosophers among them some of the most
outstanding to doubt that the whole
universe or to put it more generally all
existence was created affinity in
geometry this is an interesting passage
what's going on here is symbolic of
something larger what do they mean by
Euclidian geometry
well the Euclidean geometry there are
certain things that government time and
space and there are things that would
make sense to us they're easy to work
there are other her geometry as possible
human beings now that would mean if
there is a God God fits everything that
was good too good
he would have created human brain and do
that got to do with sort of take that
and yet I've been saying no God created
the world he created it Euclidian way
whirring would imagine things that go
beyond even what God has created the
structures that he's had and they says
of course myself I can't really
understand those nuclei now think about
that no longer in terms of geometry
think about that in terms of the human
heart in terms of the most complex thing
in creation
if God created the human being in such a
way that we're part of the universe it's
not just that God creates creation and
then we're gonna like you know extra and
then our brains are more portable thing
if God created us in such a way that
what we are would be fully explicable
fully intelligible to ourselves then we
actually could get to the bottom of the
mystery we actually could figure out
that by what we are how we did we could
have complete agreement and that's in
part with the grand inquisitor activism
and that's what either yearns for and
why he's so again one of the things that
religious thinkers have shown us in so
many different ways is that if anybody
knows what we are it's not us not not
fully at least not all the way down
there's always bits of ourselves that
sort of escape or so this is what we
call freedom one of the key themes not
only this is Grand Inquisitor thing but
what is freedom because we're three we
have the capacity
things we never even dreamed of to
escape the boundaries that seemed to be
placed upon us and yet we don't fully
understand that freedom we can even make
that use of it we can screw things up we
can destroy that's one capacitance
that's a really interesting passage I
think there are a few other passages
that I think are kind of relevant as
well once they get into the next chapter
with value
Ivan actually says I think that if the
devil doesn't exist as therefore man's
creation man has made it in his own
image that Alyosha says just as these
creative God in that case if you think
that you know supernatural entities or
the supernatural order are just
fabrications positive reflections of us
that would mean that we are in action
the highest creature creature right we
are the highest being in all of the
universe it's very interesting that he
says I mean this is pretty common to
talk about man created God even
religious figures went off from quashing
against kind of an idea of God that's
just basically us projecting their
assault on the god this is the classic
Jewish and Christian
you know the looks of profits but this
is also something that secular fingers
Bob would say that human beings have
created with their long marriage do we
greet the devil there do we think of
evil or principle that's something
really interesting to think about given
that the grand inquisitor talks about
the devil in relation to the god or the
Christ
EMP actually seems to be kind of taking
the sign of the devil causing that wise
spirit and he criticizes Christ for
resisting the temptations of the devil
he says you made a long decision and
we're going to fix things because of so
that's those are all in using passages
it's sort of three things now let's get
into the actual meat piece so I had said
that there's a narrative being laid out
by the Grand Inquisitor and it's a
narrative essentially having to do goods
and evils and temptations let's think
about this a little bit let's sort of
sketch out what do you say here's a live
in sort of a nutshell he's saying human
beings you know
human beings are beset by all sorts of
they oppressed each other they can't get
along they find ways to hurt each other
they don't feed each other they don't
treat each other right even when we
tried
that creates new forms of suffering we
can display suffering from one person to
another if God loves us God cares about
us you would think that God would come
along and try to alleviate suffering
satisfy some of our basic needs and what
it means for needs are or Goods needs
are for good things that you're lacking
and the grand inquisitor says here is
sort of you know he's covering a lot of
ground he's not trying to you know
provide it in the beginning all just
trying to say something to did this
figure of Christ he says you screwed up
you didn't do when you want to have done
when you want it done that's why we're
rejecting well
that's the the narrative within the
narrative and all the other parts of
that which we're going to look at in
greater detail fit into that general
scope yes you screwed up you didn't
solve because the divine plan looks like
like screwed up the stuff that doesn't
make sense it doesn't satisfy it works
for those strong those people the Saints
who you know you know are able to handle
this but for the mass of them of
humanity
even them being like this you know it's
a race to the bottom now let's fold it
into a larger what's the larger Christ
he actually shows up and it shows up
that a church
I suppose and it shows up right after
there's been a lot of debate and 100
years he's been burning day before and
when he shows up he pops up at the
church just as they're caring in the
closet a young girl who was died and
they're all born and so he goes over and
he reenact something that took place in
the New Testament in the Gospels and he
tells her to arise and he brings the
dead back to life he gets back then what
was lacking not only to that girl but to
all the people surrounding and more
breathing and he performs a miracle he
does so you know we're guessing this is
you know a replication also a unique
event taking place the grand inquisitor
season on the granite bitters Inquisitor
says get it get that guy and so as
guards go and they take it and people
are used to obedience and they're kind
of crushed down and perfect as a
suffering and they they want to listen
to him so Christ is miracle worker
this good thing is taken away he's
thrown into the cell and visitor comes
to this again and he says to him we're
gonna kill you as a matter of fact those
people who you were helping yesterday
they're gonna help us kill you they're
gonna be right there and they're gonna
cheer
why is that this is when he goes his
whole narrative I want to tell us about
a little bit at the end I'll just get
the head before we come back into the
heart of that that story Christ doesn't
say anything the Grand Inquisitor tries
to provoke of a few times wants to get
angry because you realize is that what
he's doing is you know posed to price
and sort of co-opted and
the only thing that ends up happening in
the very end is Christ kisses him and we
don't know what the significance of that
truth is Christ kisses is that mark of
love is it's telling him something like
I give news saying it's all right I
don't know what I do know is that the
visitor tells him get the hell out of
here do you know opens the door and
shoes him out for the night so he's not
going to execute yeah Ivan says you know
that kiss stayed with and what he has is
a very coherent ideology so let's look
at that ideology and here is I think
where we come to the real part the
chapter I think that this is fundamental
and evils tenant and temptation what
this is fundamentally about is goods
evils temptations this is the heart the
narrative itself the heart of this
chapter so looks let's actually live in
those often freedom these are two things
that end up getting left out or rather
misconceived behind the grand inquisitor
and I think to a certain extent maybe
even this conceived by my high and I
think that one of the lessons this piece
is trying to teach us not by coming
straight up and telling us that but
indirectly by making us think of that it
is it's trying to challenge us to think
about our own understandings of love and
freedom as to goods that really ought to
be seen as the highest puts the ones
that you don't trade other things for
the ones that make everything else work
because what goes on in this the a grand
inquisitor narrates this this whole
process by which human beings for these
things for these goods give up lot of
they give their long to something that
they want not and they throw away or
give over there these correspond to
temptations and this is where this is
why things dose to the espys most genius
moved here he has the Grand Inquisitor
this passage of Scripture which you find
enough already after where Christ goes
out to the desert and then after fasting
for 40 days the devil comes to tempt the
devil has three different temptations
one of the temptations is to deal with
hunger that's the price is hungry and
the devil said is look at these rocks
over here
tsongkhapa turn them into bread then you
won't be hungry and the inquisitors
talking about this not just in terms of
redford for Christ alone but you know
you can do this for everyone today you
know if you think about hospitals there
are stories where people are hungry and
Jesus feeds them regular the multitude
the multiplication of the loaves and
fishes which resulted in multitude
feeding the multitude that happens a
couple different times in the scriptures
and they actually have so much leftover
there's more than they started with so
it's not as if there isn't any of that
going on but it's sort of capricious God
chooses when he's going to do that he
doesn't say dole he doesn't say well he
doesn't say all right be here next
Friday and I will give you this from the
soup kitchen and
if you income below this level we're
going to give you this than that there's
nothing along those lines instead it's
always sort of random you know the
disciples after the resurrection find
Christ on the seashore he says catch
some fish
right you didn't tell them ahead of time
hey meet me a couple days after the
resurrection and nice fishing together
it's all when God chooses to do it and
this is part of what the Grand
Inquisitor doesn't he says look if you
can do it and you can do it any time
why did you choose to do that and you
read you know he says to have some very
important things I'm going to read you a
few passages he says
before you can ask people who are virgin
for even ask people who are obedient
people ask people to forget do the
things that they'd have to do you have
to actually feed them you actually have
to satisfy their basic needs and desires
he says turn these lows in to throw
these stones into loaves of bread then
we'll follow you like a fossil and
grateful or constantly fearful listed
with driving and they lose their bones
but you didn't want to deprive and
freedom and you rejected the suggestion
when you thought what sort of freedom
what they had with your obedience was
bread so price its value the freedom
that's good about breath and he not only
evaluated for himself evaluated for
human beings he wanted to leave the
optional which is in fact honor to
freedom the grand inquisitor her size
freedom is no good to you if you don't
have breath as a matter of fact people
will in fact trade freedom for Britain
in the end they will lay their freedom
at our feet and stateless enslave us but
feed us and they will finally understand
that freedom and the assurance of daily
bread for everyone are two incompatible
notions that could never coexist
they will also discover that man can
never be free because they're weak
corrupt worthless and restless so you
know he's saying
satisfy their basic needs that is a
greater the devil will offer you the
chance to do that you chose not to do it
what the hell is wrong with you
now we the second temptation then
actually at this point nobody s he or I
would rather his jungling things up
because the second temptation the devil
takes Christ up and he and he shows of
all the kingdom in the world he says hey
30 years just do me just you know sings
and Jesus rejects that as well so
however I put that second here in
apartment that's actually going to treat
it the third power or what you know the
people who are seedings of are what are
they getting out of it
the other thing that he talks about the
other temptation which he spends a lot
of time this is very interesting the
devil takes him up to the top of the
Temple in Jerusalem and he says jump now
you know there's easy like you know
trying to kill himself or something like
that no he's he's actually saying tempt
God put God to the test jump because if
you do angel intention this is a really
big temptation and there actually are
portions of scripture where God tells
people hey put me to the test I want you
to come on ask for something in this
case the temptation is there and Jesus
says I'm not going to do that yeah this
is really Dostoevsky against I have a
grand visitor tell price that you know
people will actually in order to try to
swage their conscience to have a good
conscience about things they will give
it just you know give them heavenly
bread give them the capacity to feel
okay about themselves to feel they're
connected
that things make sense you can give them
that and then they will actually be
quite happy he says where is that he
says how do we actually make this work
miracle mystery and authority people
want to be told what to do they want to
give their you know they want somebody
else to tell them they're doing the
right thing whether it's political or
economic enterprise whether it's how
they live their life as a sports fan as
a father as a mother as a child as a
consumer all these sorts of things
people want somebody else to tell them
hey you're doing the right thing you're
okay if you do things this way and
that's giving them over ones freedom for
feeling good that's a temptation and the
Grand Inquisitor says to Christ look you
have the opportunity to set things right
want to go but you didn't do it so now
that we and at this point is talking
about the church but you know this is
something that's got great implications
for not just a church we're going to
talk a little bit more about that later
but for any sort of organization
anything that would would claim to
satisfies he says you know you could
have made human beings happy if you had
just give it into this you would have
made human beings happy we laid out the
cathode I'm sure there was had to give
up a freedom sure the love that they
would have given
and counting these things not because
they actually chose to love you for your
own sake that would have been the loving
thing to do and they're the grand
inquisitor showing he got love along it
was more love for her Christ to leave
these things that's that's the sort of
soft tax the best that the grand
inquisitor beginning so the grand
inquisitor says you screwed up so now we
have to set the flat light we are going
to make it work because otherwise too
many people are in this song we're going
to actually says for the first time
think about how we can make human beings
happy we can think about human happiness
with a capital H for everybody well
almost everybody to another interesting
Christ doesn't say anything to all of us
the grand inquisitor census of his whole
speech he's laying out a sort of
systematic understanding of things the
systematic way of looking at
understanding human being in relation to
just something higher who's actually
going to carry out all of this that's
before all this coordination it's self
consciousness who's going to actually
exercise power
he says there's going to be a hundred
thousand inquisitors who are actually
not going to be happy that's the price
that they have to pay there's sort of
like in his view
was that Jesus did the Christian
narratives which is to take on the
sufferings all so that the rest of them
can in fact be happy and here they're
imagining human beings doing so these
are going to be human beings that are
actually seeing what's going on behind
the scenes and they see the lies and
they see that things are not as good as
they're being made out to be and they
see that they've taken Christianity and
sort of turned it on its head they have
to live with that they have to live with
that sovereign why is that good why is
that the way to go over to the grand
inquisitor because anything else would
be worse
should we just abandon all the rest of
them to their suffering okay God didn't
do his job now it's up to us to do
errands to do the job to take over where
God didn't follow through we're going to
follow through and then some and he says
you know if this means being in favor of
the devil then that's fine
well be will being able to devil because
the devil actually new battery than two
words here I won't say about now about
Church and organizations and so now
there's an interesting conflict of queen
of views between Ivan and Alyosha us
Ivan says you know I just makes perfect
sense this is the way the Catholic
Church is you know Jesuits just company
home right now and say this this sort of
thing
actually says it one way you gave your
power over to us that's it you didn't
choose to exercise the power we to the
church take the power and Elio should
have a certain point says hold on out of
there
I mean are you saying that the Orthodox
Church the running of Eastern Roadbuster
behaves like this because I've guessed
well I'm an orthodox mom
I'm not a Catholic but guess what
he didn't even get the Catholics right
because I don't know I'm you know some
Catholics and they don't actually behave
like this and you know maybe the Jesuits
do to a certain extent but even they
don't behave like this your candidate
you know presenting a false picture here
and then it says something really
interesting well okay I'll grant that to
you but I think there have been some
human beings through history who
actually yeah seven sorts of things in
the end the sorts of thoughts of the
Grand Inquisitor did and wanted to lay
out that kind of program and he had
those kind of ideas in mind and I think
some of them were in church as a matter
of fact the church the basis so much
because they see if my competitor now if
we think about this in our century where
are we seen these kind of promises maybe
that's going to my churches I mean it
doesn't matter how you feel about the
Catholic Church it's lost its worldly
presence which was on the wane percent
but in the 20th century you know like
Stalin at one point he asked how many
divisions does the church have I have
got this many Britain and system in the
United States has this maybe so it's not
that that's where the power what he has
claim to do that sort of thing that's
been mainly ideologies I think that you
can see within discourses and practices
of many of the communists the end even
to a certain extent the the fascist
International Socialists are integral
nationalists the sort of thing that's
being discussed at the grand inquisitor
we're going to make human beings
Kathie's they have to give us that our
freedom they have to give love but not
on their own terms and you know any sort
of supernatural transcendence thing has
to then that's not just a matter of
being on the state where the
organization has to be a face it has to
be sucked in somehow that has been
sometimes the case so that's that's
something particularly work I'd like to
think about a few other things too
before we finish up one of these is what
is it
are there different understandings of
the grand inquisitor says these people
out here who were flowing they think
they're free could that be the case in
our own society are there many people
who think that they're free when really
they are being controlled by not
necessarily some sort of you know
overarching to cover everything
totalitarian entity but what other
things that take where they
you know people think that they're being
free when really somebody else's calling
the shots playing playing their
heartstrings dealing in their emotions
supplying I think that there probably is
we could ask ourselves sometimes is that
the case for us what about the men of
the Inquisition not just the madman of
the age of the Inquisition later than
freedom at the feet of the inquisitors
but the inquisitors themselves he says
they're free
they taking on the burden of freedom
they face up to them they also face up
to the fact that most people can't
handle and they but here's something to
think about
let's assume that those day st actually
science more with and is trying to get
us to see that the grand inquisitor is
actually maybe quite attractive prospect
that would mean that he missed conceived
the nature of freedom but here you're
right he he is more creative than the
people used to see them for kind of like
cattle but in a certain sense he's not
either giving in to these temptations
makes me
at a certain point the granted visitor
says peace even death is more attracted
to me and then freedom of choice that
derives from the knowledge of good and
evil once we start to thinking knowledge
of good and evil is not the best truck -
it's not like we actually go you know
with perfect clarity
this is good this is evil it off isn't
something quite murky it's not Amanda
this is black and white with the black
and white arrival so intertwined that
they're hard to distinguish African
children they do want to look great
do we actually want to give up our
freedom because of the anxiety that it
produces for us because of the fact that
when we exercises we do deprive
ourselves
to be able to remain to that moment and
thank producer ESP is part of the
freedom to be able to for Alyosha to
look too long and to look to Christ even
though he can't make sense of them
completely and certainly can't satisfy
his brother with respect to that this is
a kind of freedom that the Grand
Inquisitor just wants to face
he doesn't recognize that it's for you
but it's not freedom a few other
interesting questions you know the Grand
Inquisitor does he actually believe in
God no God is a kind of a sort doesn't
doesn't
I mean it's talking to Christ he says
you know I believe that you did these
things you just got that wrong you
didn't do what you needed to do so here
we can ask yourself what does it mean to
believe in God does it mean to have some
sort of propositional truth there is a
God Jesus Christ always was the son he
did such a thing at such-and-such a time
where does it mean - does it mean
something more performative something
more a matter of the heart and of the
human will and action doing things the
lining is believing something like
pledging one's allegiance to something
in this case if that's it it's clear
he certainly doesn't believe in God in
this world you just thinks God didn't do
it as he should be economic instead what
is redundant Lee you know this term of
government comes up over and over again
I didn't stop this is called the rebel
by Alyosha that's why he brings up this
whole grand inquisitor passage the Grand
Inquisitor calls him himself and his the
Patriots rebels as well but he also
talks about Humanity in the whole week
the corrupt as being good guys and as
the Grand Inquisitor and the musician as
being able to sort of put them in place
so they're no longer the Daleks no
longer striving to have their own
expense of others is there another
category his rebellion always be a
mystery buddy I was glad you sir these
are sort of open questions at this this
another thing that this poem is up as
well is this question what is more right
what is the more jobs
what is more good to set things up so
they had a weak the failures the mass of
humans can sort of be channeled into the
proper areas
happiness that's we're gonna rule out
some of them some of the few and it's
going to harness some of the they got in
there stuck you know being cogs of the
machine in the Inquisition it's also
going to rule out and I'll say Jesus
Christ you better not show up again and
those who are sort of you know committed
to him and strong as he calls it sinks
they better not show up either
is it better to serve the happiness of
the majority the vast majority or is
something destroyed in that process is
something is there something vital
that's what I'm getting